الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد
اله الا
الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول
الله
حي على صلاه
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح ا
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
لا
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله.
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون.
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد فان الله تعالى
يقول في كتابه الكريم
منكم من يريد الدنيا
ومنكم من يريد الاخره
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
احد
ان سوره ال عمران
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏this was ma
that they at the enem
many compions
as a matter of fact in the ch thated
and in the f of
and under theing
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
youysically
among
‏important
over
الله سبحانه وتالى diagnosed
one of the issues one of the elements of
the hearts
that caused
or to this defeat
‏And that is as
said
there are those of you who desire the
and there are others among you who
desire the here
this chaos
this defeat that began as a victory
it has many causes
many ailements that to this and one of
‏more
what
desire
parad
however
areem
‏aller
[Silence]
‏other
‏fail
as
propre
and
desire
[Silence]
‏wish
here
the idea is you know it work out how bad
could be this life have everything
‏down to the
but here
you know you give a little you take a
little don't take it to seriously
this attitude
is incred contrary to the teachings of
our prop
because we cann have both we can't
simultaneously have it be day and
‏life
will sacriic
sacriic have made
are
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مسند عبد الله بن الامام احمد
رحمه الله تعالى ورحم الله اباهي
بن كعب
زيد بنثبت
الله صلى الله عليه وسلمد
من كانت الدنيا همه
فرق الله عليه شمله
وجعل فقره بين عينيه
ولم ياته منها الا ما كتب له
ومن كانت الاخره همه
جمع الله له شمله
وجعل غناه في قلبه
واتته الدنيا وهي راغمه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
primary focus
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏affair
will scatter his affairs for him scatter
his heart
and he will place his poverty his
inescapable poverty right in front of
his eyes
every he look he can't see what he ha
can see is
‏All is
alles
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لو انبن ادم وادي من ذهب احب ان يكون له
واديان
وفي زياده ولو كانت له واديان احب ان يكون
لهما ثالثه
لا يملا فاه الا التراب ويتوب الله على من
تاب
said صلى الله عليه وسلم
grey
of
‏wish there was a second make it even
you know even it and if he had a second
wish that there was a third to those two
the only that will finally his mouth and
close it and satisfy it is dirt
Allah forgives seeks for
this is our nature
and we are designed
الله
سبحانه وتالى
‏was not to
wascend
andes
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏if
thinking about
if you findly
contemplat life
and here is after
this is roll our sleeves up
الله سبحانه وتالى
اللهح
مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عبد اللهن الشخير
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر
‏was
ابن ادم مالي مالي وهل لك يا ابن ادم من
مالك الا ما اكلت فافنيت او لبست فابليت
او تصدقت به فامضيت
‏is con my property my
m
but human being do you
of all thatalth that you constantly over
that you give so much of your attention
is any of it really yours except that
which you put in your belly
[Silence]
‏allacy
people
‏some
unes
[Silence]
and
fail is
‏out
here and
you have
will
now someort
and what are youing about
the no
with worrying about we don't need toind
people that because theyve got that
naturally ‏And that is why Allah focuses
on telling us remember the hereafter
discipline yourself
discipline your mind and your heart do
not allow something of this world to
squeeze itself in next to the names and
attbutes of your heart keep the in hand
tool and only here in your heart
ابن القيم رحمه الله الفوائد
[Silence]
الله
said
seekure
‏and
gu andit
and attbut and knowing toise upon
that's what your was
for thisy that's all it's busy and human
being good or
‏when
they will all we will all be struck with
overwhelming wave
of regret
an overwhelming wave
of knowledge of just how tiny this world
really is and how inconsequential it
صلى الله عليه وسلم ساز معجم الطبراني
لو ان رجلا خر ساجدا من حين ان ولدته امه
حتى يموت هر حرما
لاستحقره يوم القيامه
‏wased
age in pration will look back
and that you know could moreي
[Silence]
‏us to
ben to irtive ofquage
us
اقول
لي ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه
انه هو الغفور الرحيم.
الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
توكيدا بعد تاكيد لبيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اما بعد
صلى الله عليه
الله منكم من يريد الدنيا ومنكم من يريد
الاخره
صلى الله عليه وسلم
من الدنيا
فرق الله عليه شمله الله
وجعل فقره بين عينيه
ولم ياته منها الا ما كتب
‏will
صلى الله عليه وسلم
من كانت الاخره
جعل الله
جمع الله له شمله الله
وجعل غناه في قلبه
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏are
out
to race and those teachings
who us is brave enough to truly open
heart and life to the revelation of
Allah to come in and do with it what
will
it'sful change is difficult ‏scary.
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
سبحانه وتعالى
which are
us from
teaches usحى
us and
the truth when we hear it
courage to follow and ad to it
‏for upon
العظيم اسال الله تعالى ان ينفعني واياكم
بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم اللهم
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
وكفر عنا سيئاتنا وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا
واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم
القيامه انك لا تخلف الميعاد ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك
عدل فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت
به نفسك او انزلته في كتابك او علمته احدا
من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور صدورنا
وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم علمنا
منه ما جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا نا
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان
تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك
والمشركين وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
غزه وفلسطين وفي كل مكان يا رب العالمين.
اللهم انصرهم على من عاداهم واجعل ثارهم
على من ظلمهم. اللهم اجعلهم على عدوهم
قاهرين ظاهرين منصورين يا رب العالمين.
اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم فانهم لا
يعجزونك. اللهم زلزل اركانهم وصدع بنيانهم
اللهم اقتل اجنادهم اللهم اجعل قتلاهم في
النيران واجعل احيائهم في ذل وهوان واجعل
شهدائنا في الجنان وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووادوا
shoulders
together
and willing
our
pleasell
الله اكبر سبحانك
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
الهاكم التكاثر
حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
السماوات ومن الارض ومننا ما بينه
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر اللهم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
انء الله
make
30th
‏gennah
mer
and sisternia
in
ch and jce to the victims of every
genice around the world protect the we
make us protector of the week and aer of
the refugees defender for the voiceless
their fear and peace
their fear
‏op
here.
‏will
daily basday
with him are about 10 to 15 minut and
upon and
spirit needs in today's world
there will be with youth on ju 11th and
18th which will be today and the next
frid from magrib to is by the way if
part of the announcement groups these
are part of the announcement
12 190
all have time at the end to ask question
to getice what they might need be so we
than him for being here taking the time
out of schedule to join us reward him
generously on that that being said the
MCCT
‏schmer
alles
back schلام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته.